welcome to cloud on air live webinars
from Google cloud we're hosting webinars
every Tuesday my name is Corey peal and
I'm a customer engineer we're joined by
Sean Ma product manager at trifecta and
we're going to talk about wrangling your
data with cloud data prep you can ask
questions anytime on the platform and we
have Googlers on standby to answer them
so let's get started with our see each
hat so Sean one of the things we want to
do today is to talk about a bit of an
overview of cloud data prep and there's
some really interesting applications and
use cases and I know you have a
wonderful demo for us we're looking
forward to that and then we'll talk
about some benefits and next steps right
however when we're looking at trifecta
when people think about data prep and
Google you talk a little bit more about
who is trifecta sure yeah trifecta is a
company that was started in 2012 and
we're based our founders are doing
research at Stanford and Berkeley and
their goal was to create enable users
for dramatic productivity and radical
creativity with their data thanks like
I've been with trifecta for the last
four years and specifically working on
the cloud data prep product for the last
two years oh great and so since your
company has been around for over six
years why do you guys decide to build a
product in this space collaborating with
Google sure so data today as you know
there's a lot of it and it's messy and
diverse and too often the key pieces of
information that you need are hidden
inside patterns of data that are hard to
get to because aided because you can't
understand what you have and you don't
actually have an easy way to process it
and understand transform it so our goal
is to make sure that people who use data
as their livelihood they can fit they
can fix the data and make it available
to whatever they need and a trifecta or
we were really focused on answering
those questions for users and making
sure that they're successful with their
jobs oh that's great so it sounds like
we're really able to use
to help people get insight into a lot of
data to solve problems of all types and
dealing with science commercial but
public service social problems that's
great yeah so why don't I saw up with a
overview of the cloud data prep product
just kind of set the stage for folks who
are new to the new to it data prep is
been around since September in in beta
mode it's been around for a couple
months now but I think just us start
things going so I used to ask the
question like you know what's I know why
did we start why did we start a company
to focus on data prep and a big reason
why is some of these statistics I'm
showing here right we've seen majority
of the time data scientists view data
preparation as the least enjoyable part
of the work but it's absolutely
necessary to get it done on the flip
side it's not just data scientists who
see this but oftentimes analysts also
spend a ton of time on data preparation
and once again it's something that they
don't want to necessarily work on it
because it's actually taking away time
from answering those key questions get
their job done so when we talk to
organizations about hey what are some of
the challenges with understanding your
data and turning that data into insight
there are two big things that come up
the first one is setting up and managing
an infrastructure that allows you to
host a large amount data of diverse
types and then process a huge amount of
it the second part is often then after
you have that not having the tools and
skill set necessary to prepare the data
so you actually can do the downstream
analysis so the key thing here is
through the combination of Google cloud
platform and its infrastructure with
ability to immediately handle in pretty
much infinite scale and then leveraging
a purpose-built tool like did like try
factor for data preparation we want to
get we want to get data into the hands
of more users and let them be as
efficient as possible in processing
their data and that leads to data
preparation and service
that's what cloud EDA prep is right it's
it allows you to visually explore data
clean it structure it weather structure
unstructured data or combine and modify
structured data with the whole goal of
making sure that zero infrastructure no
need to deploy a managed environment and
of course not needing to know how to
code
great so where does this fit inside the
data lifecycle so as you can see here
this is a typical life cycle for anyone
who works with data you take raw data
upfront and then you're going through a
kind of a discovery mode understanding
what's inside your data structuring that
cleansing it followed by enriching it
combining with other data sources
validating it to make sure it meets what
you need and this is a very iterative
loop this is something that you might do
multiple times and go forward from there
before you decide that this is that
you've prepared - there - what you need
you automate that so you can do
repeatedly for downstream analytics or
some sort of machine learning or
modeling now now the goal with data prep
is to make this process here as
efficient as possible and reduce the
time you spend on it so for example
instead of it normally taking months or
weeks ago to solve this problem and go
through all the different steps we
really want to make it days and hours
does that's one part of the efficiency
the other part is actually to enable
different types of users to actually
access the data so this is not just for
data scientists or data engineers but
also analysts people who are actually
using the end results these analytics we
want them to have access to tools that
can prepare data as well great so it's
gonna take a little bit about the
governance process because I think some
of us when we're dealing with these
types of problems we end up on these
steering committees and they have a lot
of activities a lot of roles in terms of
who needs to do what and what part of
the process and as you mentioned
typically that is a really long process
so here it looks like you have a tool
and it's available for users and various
roles within this lifecycle so maybe
that's like a little bit about
governance presence so since this is a
single tool that we'll show you in a
moment you'll be anyone will be able to
see the exact same set of transformation
so regardless of what role you are let's
say you're in the governance role and
I'm the analyst that's generating the
transformations we'll both be able to
see the exact same logic that I've been
using and step and you'll be able to
review step by step on how I got to that
because it's a single tool we won't be
like passing e-mails back and forth
we'll just literally be able to work off
of the same piece of information that
sounds great I'm sure auditors will love
that traceability as well yeah so let's
move on to some applications in use
cases that we've seen data prep for at a
high level some of the applications that
we've seen here are data on boring this
is a scenario where we see we see
analysts what are dealing with
third-party data typically data coming
from external vendors or human generated
data where there's a lot of information
on data but you need a standardized it
and you need to restructure the data in
order to meet internal standards so then
it can be fed into you know built in
pipelines you can fill into reports down
down down the stream the next one is
data science in machine learning right
so data prep is not just a challenge for
analysts it's also for data scientists
because what's the point of training a
model on a particular feature if the
quality of the data is poor that can
lead to very skewed results so making
sure that you've got the right data you
isolate the right features feeding that
into the model is important the last one
is actually the most common one we've
heard which is big data analytics right
and the challenge of beginner analytics
is that now as more more details
available of different formats it's not
just about you know it's not just about
processing traditional or relational
data it's actually combining that data
with social media commodity or file data
clickstream data so you can get a very
holistic view of what's going on in your
environment and analyze data based on
that great yeah so when you're looking
at this you have a lot of different
options you support a lot of different
use cases and in particular when we're
thinking about like you mentioned
machine learning so let's talk a little
bit about how companies are leveraging
data prep for machine learning models
and what you need to do before you start
your feature engineering yeah so I can
give an example of a healthcare company
so they actually started with actually
analytics so their challenge was so this
is a large healthcare provider they have
dozens of hospitals hundreds of
outpatient facilities throughout the
United States and their challenge was
understanding the resources both people
medicines machines resources across all
these and across all these locations
understanding what's there and how you
know kind of how the
inventory was talked across that so the
first time I'm just gathering all this
information from the various system
traditional systems customer you know
user generate information gather at a
single location just to get a good
picture of what's going on and they were
able to do that through big data
analytics using big data Alex because
they could see holistically all the
datasets combined and blend it together
great but once they had that what was
interesting about it was that same data
was then useful for actually feeding
into a machine learning model in this
case it was a flu predictor model so
what they could do was they could
actually use the information from where
inventory was where it was being used up
to help feed into a model and predict
where there was most likely going to be
a flu outbreak because they saw
inventories dip they saw patterns coming
in so that's actually a case where big
data analytics eventually fed into a
machine learning use case and they were
able to deploy that and the benefit of
us all that's great ok so these are some
of the use cases so these are some of
the applications let's talk about some
of the tasks and users that we've seen
with data prep I mentioned this before
but it's a fairly wide range of users
that we that we've seen with cloud data
prep from data scientists pretty much
anyone who uses data or their analysts
or engineers and as you can see here
there are a set of tasks that are common
across them so those include formatting
restructuring getting data into into a
format that you will understand so you
can you can do things with it then
profiling that data to get a sense of
the shape of the data itself right so
you can understand the characteristics
how clean it is what are some of the
potential anomalies inside that data and
then university what we've seen is that
no matter what the data is dirty and
needs to be cleansed so standardizing
and fixing out common issues so that's
kind of like the common tasks that we've
seen across all then we've seen data
scientists in particular but to some
degree data engineers focusing on
pattern identification and distribution
models as well as as I mentioned
training ml models for predict
predictions and usage down the load so
that's kind of where we seen a lot of
pattern data science is there engineers
now
what's interesting is that after you've
got the data in the format that you want
everyone wants to do some sort of ad hoc
analysis now they now you can know if
you understand the data better you can
explore better you can find new insights
inside of that and what you do you
typically want to enrich the data
combining with all their data sources
and with the end goal for analysts in
particular to visualize it in some sort
of dashboarding UI or bi capability okay
so how does data preparation differ from
ETL because some of these common themes
around enrichment and cleansing are
often a part of that type of process as
well yeah it's a great question
something that we get quite often so
it's not black and white in fact
oftentimes these two concepts are
complementary to each other right
typically ETL is focusing on
well-defined structured data while data
prep is handling unstructured complex
data that's coming in from non
relational sources so that's one area
but as part of that you also see a
difference in the style in which the
tools behave so data prep solutions
typically combine visualization with
machine learning all put together into
an interactive user interface so that it
can access multiple users while ETL is
focusing on a metadata driven mapping
that connects
kind of a flow through the data so these
two are complementary but they're really
targeting different types of users and
then I'd say one key difference that you
might choose is that the time to insight
in particular if you're dealing with
ad-hoc data and/or data sources that are
changing quite a bit you may want to use
data prep because it has a little bit
more flexibility for these changes and
go for from there oh great well I'd love
to see how this works in action yeah
well so I've got a quick demo
to go through so hopefully highlighting
some of the capabilities of data prep
before I start I'm actually going to go
ahead and just give some context on this
demonstration and then I'll jump into
the product itself so this demo as you
can see here I've got actually two data
sets on the left-hand side here one is a
click stream file you can see it's kind
of it's got URL information and gates
and click behavior I want to take this
clickstream data and combine it with
sales order data from my website this
web web order data is stored in my
stored and bigquery so I want to combine
that with the goal of generating a nice
dashboard to understand you know where
things are being where consumers have
been purchasing from as well as one of
the most often clicked items and do they
need two orders so things I want to pull
out of that is a correlation between
clicks and orders I want to extract out
products that have been purchased and
any you know get a sense of the quantity
for that and of course during this whole
process I'll be cleansing the data
preparing it for this downstream
dashboarding view okay so let's switch
off - let's switch off and actually get
into the product itself
so how just starting from the beginning
how much she's launched cloud cloud data
prep well in the cloud console you can
go to the menu here you can go down to
the Big Data section and you'll see data
prep all right so clicking on that
that'll launch data prep from the
console and I quickly full screen this
and I like to have my big data items
pinned as well so those are using the
console mate to have it at the top after
you start playing around with it
definitely so once you enter your cloud
data prep you'll see this this workspace
where you're kind of showing all the
flows basically organizations of
analysis that you're working on and for
this particular demonstration I'm going
to create a new one so I'm create a new
flow I'm going to call it click to order
analysis and go ahead and create that
and I mentioned that my data sets were
in Google Cloud storage and bigquery as
files and a table so I'm actually going
to import that live as you can see here
this is inside data prep you can browse
through cloud storage so I'm actually
browsing the buckets that are default in
my project inside of this take a look at
some of the folders I see website click
stream data
I see ok click seem across multiple
years I'd look inside just take a quick
look inside is this the data that I'm
looking for yep this looks kind of what
the data I'm looking for so what I want
to do is I actually want to take for
this demonstration I'll just take fiscal
year 2010 as my starting
point for my clicking data so I've added
that here uh a whole folder yeah I've
added that whole folder it's my
clickstream data source and then then I
need to go take a look at bigquery so
now again I'm browsing the bigquery data
sets available inside my project I'm
looking inside this one do a quick skim
nope this is not what I'm looking for so
let me go back well I bet it's under
here okay so taking a look at this I see
customer sales master it's got half a
billion rows there and then I've got the
only customer sales for this
demonstration I'll probably take the
daily customer sales just just to make
for a quick demonstration so daily
customers I'll just do customer sales
okay
so as you can see here I've got the two
data sets I do want to mention that if I
didn't have my data sets in Google Cloud
Storage of bigquery I can actually
upload data whether it's CSV JSON or
Excel files so you can also upload it
and make your data set but let's go
ahead with the two data sets that I have
here so go ahead and import that so now
you see is representations of those data
sets in cloud data prep just so we're
clear these are read-only
representations so I'm not actually
modifying those data and I'm gonna start
with the clickstream data and I'm gonna
start preparing it so in order to do
that I'm gonna go in and I want to take
a look at it within the data prep you I
so if you recall when we first look at
the raw data it was kind of jumbled it
was hard to understand what data prep
does out of the box is it actually scans
the data tries to understand its best it
will break it up into easy to read rows
and columns where possible and as part
of rows and columns of do things like
identify the call names so this is
probably in the file itself as well as
infer data types so in this case it's
inferring that this is a date/time if
you keep going things URL their various
data types that data data prep can infer
so it will automatically apply them
without you having to do anything the
next thing you might notice at the top
is what's known as a quality bar so
that's this item up here it kind of
gives you how many items inside this
particular column match the data type
that's up here and looking at event time
I can see while there's a lot of matches
up here I
see actually quite a bit of mismatched
values and knowing data quality is
usually a big profit for any analytics
I'm actually want understand more so I'm
gonna go take a look at the column
details so I call it quick column
details and now I can see a lot more
information about the data this was date
time data I can see it distributed over
time I can see it broken up into months
and week days but the part I'm
interested in is the mismatched values
and looking at this I can clearly see
the most common mismatched value is
error time out well this is not going to
be particularly useful for us so what I
want to do is I want to get rid of it
and the way I do that is actually
interacting with this histogram here so
I'm actually going to click on this
histogram and what data prep will do is
it will actually based on that click
suggest transformations that I might
want to apply to this in this case it's
suggesting I might want to keep those
that's not the case but my second
suggestion is actually to delete the
rows so what's happening under the
covers data prep has a machine learning
model that's actually understanding
that's actually looking at what you've
been clicking on and looking at some
past behavior for forum and aggregate
across many users and suggesting
transformations in this case I'm gonna
delete all this data here so let me go
ahead and add that and you'll
immediately notice that my histograms
have been updated with the fact that
that those rows of data have been
deleted now still looking at this I
still see mismatched values so there's
still a problem
I still see more issues here seems to be
something wrong with a date but I don't
quite understand it so I'm actually
gonna take a look at the patterns view
of this column and take a look at what's
inside of that now looking at here data
premise scan that column and identified
there are three patterns for this date
I'm field I see your year month Monday
day 24 hours minutes and seconds the
next one is your month date but 12-hour
million seconds and then I see these
ones here which are the month
abbreviation which definitely is going
to cause an issue so knowing that I'm
actually going to do analytics with this
most systems don't like having different
date formats what I'm going to do is I'm
actually going to click on the format
that I want which is this one here and
once again data prep will suggest
various transformations
and the one I'm most interesting is
actually converting converting the other
patterns into a standard one here and
the other prep is showing me a preview
in the blue was what the original data
looks like in the yellow is actually
what it's paws what is suggesting the
transformation - so I can see that
November will be converted into a number
and 12 hour time format changing to 24
hour time format so that that looks like
what I got what I want so I'm gonna go
ahead and apply that and go ahead and
add it great so now I don't have any
more issues my data is all one pattern
let's go back and take a look at the
grid view itself and again this is all I
just remind this is I'm not actually
changing the source data at this point
all this is happening within my browser
so it's just happening in this view here
so this one looks with the event time
looks good I'm gonna keep going
looking at these quick histograms across
I can see distribution data I see
something weird going on with user ID
hmm normal I would expect this to be you
know a much better distribution there's
clearly one user ID that's sticking out
it's actually happening out many more
times than others so I'm just gonna
select that and I'm actually gonna view
which rows this is affecting so looking
at that user ID I can see it's all
coming from the same URL oh that's weird
the event time for this these clicks are
all happening the same time okay this
could be a bot of some sort so you know
what I don't think this is gonna be
useful for analytics so for this case
I'm actually gonna go ahead and delete
it so I'm gonna choose to delete those
rows and add that in and immediately
data prep will show me the redistributed
data so I'm just looking around and the
URL looks a bit more even okay the last
part I know I need to do was extract the
Product ID I was looking at was
interesting to see when people click
what product they were clicking through
on so let's take a look at the URL
normally a product these ID is part of
that and lo and behold yup you can see
this at the end of the URL you see
product ID and the number and you can
see that for different products going
forward so my next step is I want to
extract this information out and and
use it for using it in my dashboard so
how am I do that well a data prep you
can just click and highlight the data
that you're interested in and that same
that same machine learning model that's
providing suggestions well actually take
that data that I've selected and suggest
a pattern that matches it so in this
case it's a pattern and apply to all the
rows so and and here you see a preview
of the data that's extracted this is
looking pretty good I'm gonna go ahead
and add that then one last step I
probably want to know where which
website this is coming from but I don't
need to know all this information the
page information so I'm actually going
to click on their URL and I'm gonna say
take a look at ability to extract the
domain so I'm actually going to choose
to extract the domain yep it's pulling
out the domain information for this that
looks like what I'm looking for cool so
I'm gonna add that to my data as well so
now I've pulled out two key attributes
the domain and Product ID overall this
is looking like pretty good great so I
think my clicking data is at the state
down looking for my next step is to
combine this with the customer order
data that's stored in the bigquery table
so before I do that I actually want to
just take a moment to note everything
I've been doing has been stored in
what's known as a recipe and these
recipes contain individual
transformation steps based on your user
actions so as you can see here every
single step that I've done has shown up
here and the nice part is that if I ever
want to go back and kind of understand
what's going on how my transformations
has was performed I can actually go back
and click and see what the data looked
at like before I applied that
transformation I can also edit a
transformation so if I've made a mistake
and I want to edit something I can go
ahead and do that I don't want to do in
this case I can just replay this is
really helpful in particular when you're
doing data governance and other people
won't understand what's going on they
can literally step through one by one on
what you're all operating really as
auditors will love this yeah alright so
let's go ahead and combine that previous
data set so I'm actually going to add a
new step and would actually join data in
so I am going to look at what Diaz said
so I pulled in earlier customer sales
was looking
let me just preview that just to make
sure this is what I wanted taking a
quick look
yup sales order key yeah and customer
key okay this is looking look what I
want so let's go ahead and choose the
joint keys so behind-the-scenes data
prep is actually analyzing the two data
sets and it's actually gonna come back
with a recommendation on how to best
join the data and they'll behold it is
suggesting that I combine the data based
on user ID and customer ID once again do
a quick scan this looks like it makes
sense great so so these are two columns
that's joined on I actually want more
columns inside of this so I'm gonna add
all them I'm gonna remove the customer
key for this and I probably don't need
customer this information but this is
probably what I'm looking for here yep
so now I select the columns quick
preview on what I want and now I'm gonna
add this join to the recipe itself so
this this join like I said earlier was
gonna be down in the browser and when I
scan through my new data set view I can
see not only my original collection data
but now I can see all that joined in
data with a sales order key ordered
eight customer stay customer zip code
cool so this is actually looking pretty
good I think I have all the information
that I need let's see if there's any
other things I pull out
oh I notice something what is this sales
order lines hmm this is kind of
interesting it looks a little bit Oh
actually looks kind of complicated oh
yeah that's good
oh it looks like there's some nested
data inside uh inside of a query table
great looks like I'm gonna have to get
that get that out that's not gonna be
fun well let's see well data prep has
figured out that this is an array so let
me see if I click on the column let's
see what I suggests okay um it's
actually suggesting that it might
flatten the array into new row so
convert each of these items into
individual rows so let's see what that
looks like I'm just gonna select that
okay now it's
pulling out each item yeah it's looking
at each line item in the sales order and
pulling down to individual row okay it
duplicated the rest of the information
that's good okay so this is looking good
so I'm gonna add this in so it's flatten
that out and now notice that the
histogram is also changed it's actually
broken it down into the elements inside
this object so this is a sales order
object I can see the interview elements
like product key ship date quantity
well the histogram is actually updated
to show those same things so now if I
want to pull out just those pieces
information I can click on product key
here in the histogram and it will
extract that out I'm also interested in
quantity so I'm actually gonna add
quantity to this and go ahead and add it
there great so I'm gonna add that
quickly to this okay I've got product
key and quantity all right one last step
and then we'll and then going so now
I've got the data in the format that I
wanted I want to run this against I want
to run this and process a full result so
what I'll do is I'll go ahead and run
job by default data prep will generate a
CSV file but you can change this at any
point so I'm going to go ahead and click
on this if I wanted to change it to a
JSON file I can so I I could generate
that but in addition to that I actually
want to publish this to bigquery so I'm
actually going to go back into bigquery
I'm going to go to this demo environment
and I'm going to create a new table I
want to call this clickstream data but
instead actually once you call it click
to order analysis okay great
I'm going to save the settings so I've
chosen to append this table after every
one so if I run this again and again
you'll just keep it pending so I saved
that setting and then I'm gonna click
run jump so what's happening under the
covers is that data prep is taking that
recipe converting that into a data flow
job and now that data flow job will be
executed it gets a source data and
generate a new target result if you want
to take a look at what that looks like
so I can go
more and I can view the dataflow job
itself just see what that's being kicked
off yeah right so that's looking good
okay so this is gonna take a little time
so through the magic of demos I'm gonna
go to a previously completed job so I
have a couple jobs that I've completed
here I'm gonna take a look at what the
result looks like click on View results
and there I get to see a whole view
detailed view a profile view of all the
data that was wrong how many rows you're
generating across all the columns okay
this is looking good the last thing I
want to do on the demo is then what I
want to do is take this data set and
actually go back so go back to my click
to order analysis and what I want to do
is then schedule this for repeated runs
so I'm gonna how to go ahead and add a
schedule this on a weekly basis Sunday
actually I'm going to do Monday at 9:00
a.m.
great okay so that's about it I've got
this scheduled I can go program its
destination I'm done with my demo that's
excellent and you did that in a matter
of minutes as some of us have had to
deal with a lot of meetings and sequel
scripts and cron jobs and a lot of other
tools integrated just to get to that
result so this is a great demo really
impressive thank you so a quick recap so
what did we just do we just add data
from various data sources we went that
was prepared through data prep which was
and then data prep use cloud dataflow to
generate the refined data which is then
loaded into bigquery and from there you
can use that for duty through data
studio or cloud ml so I'm going to
quickly recap you know some of the key
benefits and capabilities we just saw
you saw a lot of you saw the first one
which is interactive data exploration as
use as you see patterns in the data you
can literally click on them and click on
them will generate predictive
transformations those transformations
were based on what you clicked on the
type of data and the and the model
underneath the model needs would suggest
transformations that might apply and
then when you do any of these actions
you get immediate feedback as to what
they might do and then the key kind of
benefits for this whole solution is that
it's all fully managed the entire
solutions self service anyone who has
access to
your console can then access the data
and explore it and then they can
generate a repeatable data preparation
pod okay well with that I'm going to
kind of wrap up and just talk wrap-up
with the next steps all I can say is
that if you want to try this out go to
your console and you can launch cloud
data prep today from there you can enjoy
tutorial and start wrangling your own
data okay great so you see the URL to go
to cloud that Google com size data prep
so stay tuned for a live Q&A we will be
back in less than a minute thanks
you
welcome back so Sean we have a few
questions from the audience and I may
throw in a few of my own as well so
what's next with cloud data prep and
there are some new features you want to
hightlight
of course so there's actually quite a
lot to talk about what's coming next for
cloud data prep where you know if you
stay tuned there'll be some
announcements coming out soon but we're
focusing a lot on providing new
developer productivity enhancements so
allowing users to to transform the data
more efficiently with additional tools
we're also focusing a lot on team based
collaboration and sharing so that's some
things that we're looking in a fairly
short order and of course overall will
be be enhancing some of the favorite
features people like to use and
particularly with scheduled jobs
enhancing that and soon you'll see a new
revamp to the overall UI Oh excellent
and so how many customers have adopted
data prep so far and is this supported
globally yeah so actually yes data prep
is supported globally in fact as part of
this we have almost a thousand different
organizations sign up for data prep
around the world at this point they're
literally running thousands of jobs a
day and we've seen a lot of interest out
of Asia out of Europe I mean pretty much
everywhere you can think of we've seen
Gator prep users okay great and so when
you run a job where those the data
processing take place and those data
prep store data sure so as I mentioned
when I went through the demo when you
click on run job oh what's happening is
that data prep is taking that recipe the
steps that are defined inside that
recipe translating that into a dataflow
job that you saw on the screen that went
through execution that data that
dataflow job reads data from your G
source data from your GCP project
transforms that data transforms a data
within your GC a project and writes it
back out into the same project so
actually the data always stays within
that project and doesn't leave it and
all the processing is done there in
terms of storage of data data data prep
self doesn't store any data because what
you're actually seeing what we're doing
is we're actually asking dataflow to
actually run the processing and generate
the new data set less land so that way
if I need to keep all my data in Europe
and I have my project set up to be only
in Europe same rules for cloud storage
then that's where it stays ok great ok
and well I know if some people really
like to know more about pricing when it
comes to some of these tools do wants to
talk a little bit about the pricing
model sure it's actually very similar to
it's actually very similar to dataflow
it's based on the amount processing
resources that you take so there's a
flat a flat charge based on the total
hours then you're running a job for ok
and when we talked about a couple of use
cases so we described how people can
explore data how you have data prepared
for ML feature engineering preparing for
that but also when it comes to data
onboarding there are also some other
things people need to do for those types
of use cases so you talked a little bit
about how people are using data prep for
cloud is onboarding data onboarding yeah
so data onboarding where you're dealing
with like data that is slightly that is
similar and content but not quite of the
right structure so with data prep what
you can do you can easily we order and
restructure that data to match what you
expected standards and then from there
as you saw with the date/time example
you can actually standardized formats
fairly easily if you think about it that
was actually you know sanitizing date
time in particular is hard so maybe we
made that fairly easy to data prep oh
that's great and then the customer
dilemma a lot of people have a lot of
meetings defining what is a customer
what are the attributes from all these
different sources CRM ERP so it looks
like in terms of data onboarding or if
you're doing M&A activities this is a
really great tool to do that type of
exploration oh great and and I think you
mentioned when you were going through
the demo that you had the ability to
support different types of file formats
so you talked a little bit about how you
deal with the compressed file so the
source file may be yeah so mentioned
that we subdue to prep support see
VJs on Excel files but also supports
compression like gzip and bzip2 store
already and Google Cloud Storage able to
read that in fairly easily Oh excellent
okay and and with a factor you have and
you're marrying what you have put in
place for data prep with your experience
in those tools and that's married to our
Google Cloud infrastructure and so you
talked a little bit about trifecta maybe
expertise or professional services when
it comes to getting people set up and
getting started and trained yep so as
mentioned so we've try packages just
focus on data preparation and making
sure users accessible so as part of that
not only do we have services services
options where we can come in and do some
initial onboarding and training on how
you how you use a tool but we also have
a lot of free resources a lot of free
resources in the form of tutorials blogs
documentation so all that's available
both in the data prep documentation as
well as from type fact itself Oh
excellent yeah so it sounds like you
have everything available so if people
want to learn more about cloud data prep
they can go directly to cloud that
Google com so I stay to prep and learn a
lot more it looks like there was one
additional question or follow-up about
the pricing so just a question saying is
the pricing variable yeah so just so
we're clear the pricing is based on the
number of compute resources that you use
so whilst a fixed price for the compute
resource it's it varies based on the
number of resources so if it's taking
more hours more compute hours to execute
a job therefore the price will go up
it's just a a price on a per hour total
type of calculation hopefully that
helped okay okay great
yes well stay tuned for our next session
three reasons why you should run
enterprise workloads on gke and thanks
Sean for coming here today this has been
really informative and I know I'm gonna
start doing some additional work of my
data prep project to explore a lot of of
data without actually doing a lot of
coating so the number of hours you've
saved with that I think we all
appreciate that those are some gone
through those those sessions and the war
rooms and the meetings great right I was
happy to be here pleasure to be here
thank you all right thanks